man good for him he has so much going on
outside the Octagon this is exactly what
he needs to do good for him one of the
best man what a great career too and
he's a guy everyone loves because he
never got his dues he'll kind of have
that salty record then finally goes on
that epic run Darren till Ben askren you
know this nuts okay he's all mad hey the
only man to carry the BMF Bell that's
right that's a button yeah yeah so yeah
Darren till aspirin Nate Diaz Cerrone
like you look at his list of wins one of
the greatest runs in history and also a
fighter that blew the [__] up like
that's a great retirement fight yeah
like great retirement yeah went to
diesels with a top five guys you look
good
about to be a world champion well one of
the greatest wins of all time yeah